é o dia 24 de agosto de 2015
foi uma segunda feira um dia comum como
todos os outros
e nesse dia os jornais costumam trazer
coisas que aconteceram anteriores coisas
que acontecem no mundo coisas que
acontecem na dimensão nacional e local
que ajudam a gente se sente um pouco
mais a comunidade enfim nos dá um senso
de liga e dentro de uma sociedade pra
quem não lembra algumas coisas que
aconteceram um pouco antes desse dia é
vale lembrar que a gente teve um
atentado terrorista em paris um evento
de dimensão nacional é internacional que
nos faz compartilhar certas leis certas
incertezas mas pensando uma dimensão
nacional
a gente estava vindo de uma semana em
que começaram a fazer várias
especulações em candidaturas a
prefeituras das capitais na cidade
começaram a surgir alguns nomes e aí a
gente começa a conversar mais sobre a
política das cidades e pensando em uma
forma um pouco ainda mais próxima
foi um período em que se anunciou um
pouco em sintonia com problemas que
estão acontecendo no mundo como um todo
cortes de verbas da secretaria de estado
aqui no estado de pernambuco
mas para trazer alguns acontecimentos de
uma dimensão ainda mais local mais
próxima
24 de agosto foi o centenário e um
importante espaço cultural da cidade que
completou 100 anos fechado sem previsão
de reforma sem previsão de abertura e
comemorou essa data de uma perspectiva
um pouco mais triste
nesse dia um dos principais jornais da
cidade trouxe pra gente essa principal
manchete nós precisamos ter cuidado com
os aplicativos de bate papo
a carga de trabalho por trás dessa
manchete a gente tem um cliente por trás
desse cliente
a gente tem uma empresa que é contratada
para garantir que esse cliente saia do
jornal
então são várias coisas que estão
acontecendo e quando o jornal escolhe a
informação mais importante para a cidade
está aqui é essa ela está favorecendo um
pouco esse interesse cruzado e empresas
e clientes de notícias e tudo mais
quando isso acontece fica um pouco
evidente uma relação meio óbvia do
mercado de comunicação da esquerda
sempre porta e reforçar que a gente tem
muito mais empresas de assessoria de
comunicação do que tem redação e
significa dizer que a gente tem muito
mais conteúdo sendo produzido no estado
sendo apuradas
cid foi o dia também que a empresa por
trás daquele cliente passou a segunda
feira inteira comemorando que o seu
cliente tem sido capa do principal
jornal de um dos principais jornais da
cidade
quando essas coisas acontecem é é
reforça um pouco essa necessidade de
análise
essa é uma pergunta fácil da gente
responder porque vão ter várias
perspectivas vários pontos de vistas
diferentes né e pensar fazer jornalismo
pressupõe passado e certo modo por todas
essas perguntas então fazer jornalismo é
antes de tudo uma função social uma
necessidade que a gente tem dentro de
uma determinada sociedade de terminada a
comunidade de entender por que certas
coisas estão acontecendo investigar
conversar ouvir as pessoas dá um
tratamento é isso de uma forma que
outras pessoas possam entender e contar
essas histórias mais rapidamente essa
função social ela se transforma num
produto e quando se transformar num
produto precisa ter retorno financeiro
precisa se adequar a certas necessidades
das empresas que vão querer transformar
aquilo num produto
mas aí o jornalismo também se transforma
numa profissão
e aí quando se transforma numa profissão
entrar horário de trabalho horário de
largar salário patrão sindicato diversos
interesses juntos a esses de se
transformar num produto e juntos a este
uma função social ea função desenvolvida
dentro de uma sociedade
quando eu falo sobre isso eu gosto muito
de lembrar de uma perspectiva de um
filósofo francês chamado pierre levy que
ele diz que não existe democracia sem
uma mídia livre e falar isso significa
dizer que fazer jornalismo também tem
uma função política muito forte sentido
político muito forte e tem uma
importância ea dimensão muito grande
dentro de uma sociedade pra gente
lembrar um pouco o quanto isso é
importante
vale lembrar casos como o target uma
investigação de um jornal que ao seu
final forçou o então presidente dos
estados unidos deixar seu cargo targu
mais importantes da política talvez do
mundo ainda hoje não estava acima de uma
mídia livre não estava acima da
investigação do jornal
esse sentido democrático e político do
jornal do fazer jornalismo em países de
terceiro mundo tem cada vez mais se
perdido o tem cada vez mais se
distanciado porque o governo federal
estadual municipal independente de
partido independente da cidade se torna
também um cliente que também
contratações empresas de comunicação que
também e essa intermediação entre o que
está acontecendo e que vai ser dito para
as pessoas que está acontecendo
quando isso não acontece cada vez mais a
gente encontra esse jornalismo que se
rende ao que acontece ao que se fala nas
redes sociais
os boatos que circulam nas redes sociais
quando a gente tem que pensar jornalismo
uma perspectiva um pouco mais clássico a
gente lembra dos filmes e nos filmes de
jornalismo tem uma figura fundamental
central que é a fonte
aquela pessoa que tenha informação
privilegiada que justifiquem a
investigação
você conversar com outras pessoas e cada
vez mais essa fonte se torna empresas e
quando não se torna essas empresas se
tornam alguns boatos que circulam nas
conversas da gente de dia e quando isso
acontece é é a gente é independente de
posicionamento político independente de
de posicionamento do jornal começa a ter
alguns resultados que parecem soar um
pouco confuso como por exemplo a
previsão do futuro em dizer que há
alguma coisa que ainda não aconteceu vai
acontecer e muitas vezes arriscando a
previsão do futuro bem precisa não é 25
não é 30 mil são 27 mil pessoas que vão
aparecer num evento que ainda vai
acontecer quando tudo isso acontece eu
fico pensando um pouco sobre a minha
trajetória no jornalismo que é curta
ainda ano espero que ainda muita coisa
vai acontecer e eu fico pensando o
quanto eu tive de certo modo sorte em
perceber um pouco mais cedo que fazer
jornalismo não necessariamente estava
ligado em estar dentro de um jornal é
fazer jornalismo muitas vezes estava
ligado a outras coisas que eu estava
fazendo ali fora então quando estou aqui
conversando dando uma palestra
participando de um debate tem um pouco
de jornalismo aí quando estou
participando de uma curadoria de um
evento escolhendo uma programação
montando alguma coisa que outras pessoas
vão ver
passa por aí também um certo sentido de
jornalismo mas dá pra gente explicar
isso para outras coisas também então
quando às vezes você vai ser chamado
para uma festa e você quer escolher as
músicas que vão tocar naquela festa
parece uma ação mais mundana
mas até aí tem um pouco de jornalismo
também eu acho que às vezes isso parece
uma visão um pouco romantizada mas é uma
visão que eu compartilho bastante e que
existe jornalismo em diversas
plataformas diversas coisas que a gente
faz em todos os dias da gente e com o
tempo isso foi uma coisa que eu acabei
trazendo para a minha realidade hoje de
professor dando aula de jornalismo uma
das coisas que a conta
se todos os dias começo de semestre e
começo de ano letivo principalmente são
aqueles alunos que chegam com angústia é
natural de quem é que vai me contratar
com a empresa que eu vou trabalhar
qual é o salário qual é o dia da folga é
e cada vez se torna uma missão um pouco
mais difícil tentar explicar que não
existe jornalismo aí que isso é uma
coisa que a gente deve tentar correr e
tentar fugir
e para tentar justificar isso acaba me
lembrando um pouco da minha trajetória
particular de novo e eu lembro que chega
a ser engraçado mas boa parte das coisas
que eu consegui fazer bem interessante
com o jornalista que marcaram a minha
carreira que fazem as pessoas olharem
para mim e falarem que eu sou jornalista
são coisas que eu fiz fora do horário de
trabalho muitas vezes gastando dinheiro
do meu próprio bolso
eu sempre escrevi muito sobre música uma
área que sempre me interessou desde o
começo da minha carreira e escrever
sobre novos artistas e para outras
cidades
conhecer ventos que até então não
chegavam por um intermédio de empresas
de assessoria de comunicação em cidades
como a nossa
era uma coisa que eu não ia conseguir
fazer uma redação porque ia se esbarrar
em questões trabalhistas em questões de
hora extra de salário em questões de
interesses empresariais
em todas essas relações do produto é que
se o produto que é o jornal e e um certo
modo trabalharem redação quando eu
passei pelos três jornais da cidade
acabou se tornando uma forma que eu
tinha de conseguir dinheiro para viver a
minha vida pagar minhas contas para a
escola da minha filha mas para conseguir
fazer um jornalismo que eu queria fazer
fora da redação e é interessante ter
feito esse percurso dentro da música
porque em contato com novos músicos um
novo mercado de trabalho eu percebi que
essa era uma angústia meu compartilhada
muitas vezes um músico no começo da sua
carreira ele precisa encontrar outras
formas de se sustentar para poder fazer
a música que ele gostaria de fazer pra
não se rendeu à pressão de uma indústria
que certa sua criatividade que cerca a
forma como ele vai ter que
com pouco a forma como ele vai ter que
se vestir a forma como ele vai ter que
se apresentar
então a saída às vezes um pouco dura mas
por trás dela em essa necessidade
criativa do artista em que um de certo
modo o trabalho acabei relacionando com
a necessidade de fazer jornalismo e de
conseguir sustentar isso de alguma forma
e e se tornou um desafio que eu tento
compartilhar todos os dias e que a gente
precisa afastar um pouco esse senso de
profissão esse senso de produto e
encarar a fazer o jornalismo como missão
de vida que a gente para prestar atenção
em algumas das principais histórias que
estão sendo contadas hoje isso que pode
ser visto também como uma visão
romantizada vai estar por trás de alguns
dos melhores exemplos que a gente tem
para trazer como é o caso da própria
mídia ninja um grupo de pessoas que
percebendo que certas histórias
importantes sobre o momento político do
país não apenas estava deixando de ser
contada já estavam deixando estava
passando a ser contada de uma forma
enviesada é foram para as ruas não
apenas para protestar mais pra contar
essas histórias também aí a gente tem o
jornalismo como um sentido de vida uma
missão de vida coisas que ultrapassam
por exemplo a própria formalidade da
universidade que vai ensinar como fazer
jornalismo mas que principalmente
ultrapassam certas burocracias do
mercado de trabalho não são coisas que
vão ajudar a gente entender o caso da
pública uma agência que começou a
procurar fomento em outras áreas para
distribuir uma coisa que ele chama de
bolsa reportagem quem está interessado
em contar a história a gente interessada
em financiar isso para que essas
histórias possam ser contadas sem o
intermédio de interesse comercial
entanto o interesse de outras empresas
de que vão estar contratando quem quer
que seja para poder formatar manchetes
de jornais também é o caso de marco zero
é que por sua vez até procuram
financiamento que nem chega a ser mais
financiamento empresarial mas nem ter um
financiamento de pessoas físicas
mesmo quem tem interesse de ver
histórias a serem contadas com o mínimo
de responsabilidade com alguma apuração
a gente tem disposição de contar elas
energia marco zero transforma essa
angústia de quem quer me contratar uma
necessidade de contar histórias de uma
forma que não passe pelo interesse do
contratante
então deixa de ser um pouco essa esses
exemplos ajuda a gente entender que
deixa de ser um pouco essa visão
romantizada de um jornalismo mais uma
visão real é é então eu termino a minha
fala fazendo essa provocação para que a
gente encontre em ações do nosso dia a
dia do nosso cotidiano forma de fazer
jornalismo isso significa a gente não se
render por exemplo a superficialidade de
informação a gente não simplesmente ler
o título e compartilhar a gente não
simplesmente ver a foto e achar que ele
entender o que está acontecendo mas
investigar ouvir as pessoas conversar
com as pessoas da tratamento a
informação que a gente recolhe e
repassar para outras pessoas porque aí a
gente redes cobra nosso sentido
democrático do jornalismo e é isso que
eu estou chamando aqui ainda talvez numa
perspectiva um pouco romantizado eu
reconheço mas do jornalismo como missão
de vida o jornalismo que que movimenta
nossa necessidade de estar conectado
enquanto sociedade e dar sentido a gente
está conectado enquanto sociedade
obrigado